[Music]
whether it's being chained to a burning
wheel turned into a spider or having an
eagle one sliver Greek mythology is
filled with stories of the gods
inflicting gruesome horrors on mortals
who angered them yet one of their most
famous punishments is not remembered for
its outrageous cruelty but for it's
disturbing familiarity Sisyphus was the
first king of ephyra
now known as Corinth although a clever
ruler who made his city prosperous he
was also a devious tyrant who seduced
his niece and killed visitors to show
off his power this violation of the
sacred hospitality tradition greatly
angered the gods but Sisyphus may still
have avoided punishment if it hadn't
been for his reckless confidence the
trouble began when Zeus kidnapped the
nymph Aegina carrying her away in the
form of a massive ego a Gina's father
the River God I suppose pursued their
trail to ephyra where he encountered
Sisyphus in exchange for the God making
a spring inside the city the king told I
suppose
which ways use had taken the girl when
Zeus found out he was so furious that he
ordered Thanatos or death to chain
Sisyphus in the underworld so he
couldn't cause any more problems but
Sisyphus lived up to his crafty
reputation as he was about to be
imprisoned the king asked Thanatos to
show him how the chains worked and
quickly bound him instead before
escaping back among the living with
Thanatos trapped no one who could die
and the world was thrown into chaos
things only returned to normal when the
God of War Ares upset the battles were
no longer fun freed Thanatos from his
chains
Sisyphus knew his reckoning was at hand
but he had another trick up his sleeve
before dying he asked his wife
Merapi to throw his body in the public
square from where it eventually washed
up on the shores of the river Styx
now back among the dead Sisyphus
approached Persephone queen of the
underworld and complained that his wife
had disrespected him by not giving him a
proper burial Persephone granted him
permission to go back to the land of
living and punish Merapi on the
condition that he would return when he
was done of course
Sisyphus refused to keep his promise now
having twice escaped death by tricking
the gods
there wouldn't be a third time as a
messenger hermes dragged Sisyphus back
to Hades the King had thought he was
more clever than the gods but Zeus would
have the last laugh Sisyphus his
punishment was a straightforward task
rolling a massive boulder up a hill but
just as he approached the top the rock
would roll all the way back down forcing
him to start over and over and over for
all eternity historians have suggested
that the tale of Sisyphus may stem from
ancient myths about the rising and
Setting Sun or other natural cycles but
the vivid image of someone condemned to
endlessly repeat a futile task has
resonated as an allegory about the human
condition in his classic essay the myth
of Sisyphus existentialist philosopher
Albert Camus compared the punishment to
humanity's futile search for meaning and
truth in a meaningless and indifferent
universe instead of despairing Camus
imagine Sisyphus defiantly meeting his
fate as he walks down the hill to begin
rolling the rock again and even if the
daily struggles of our lives sometimes
seem equally repetitive and absurd we
still give them significance and value
by embracing them as our own for more
literary takes on defiance in the face
of seemingly insurmountable challenges
we highly recommend man's search for
meaning Victor Frankel's chilling
first-hand account of life in the
Auschwitz concentration camp you can
download a free audio version at
audible.com slash ted-ed